what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
my dog is probably the dumbest creature
that ever lived I swear to god is this
dogs dumber than a box of hammers anyway
guys what is up
absolutely love my dog what is going on
guys for those of you guys who don't
know myself comics Torian and Natalie
adds article candy we run a channel
called elgible monster make sure you
guys check that out because we did like
a hide and seek custom game for
overwatch we actually found that mode on
the internet and it was really really
fun to play it was really cool but
anyway we are back into it with secret
Empire and this is cool because secret
Empire is rapidly proving to be one of
my absolute favourite stories when it
comes to the Captain America landscape
and Marvel comics at the moment
ironically enough it's like this an old
man Logan or like the only two things
that I'm reading and the Mighty Thor I
took a little bit of a break from the
Mighty Thor during secret Empire because
it's literally just what Jane Foster is
doing while Secret empires going on
which we might cover she just in some
weird dimension but she came back in the
most recent story so it's still kind of
cool but the idea here is with secret
Empire we are getting into basically the
crescendo which is to say the point at
which we reach the peak and then things
start going down into the conclusion of
the story which you if you are current
with secret Empire is amazing remember
dude that's oh my god it's one of the
coolest moments the most recent one that
just came out issue number 9 it spills
the beans on what the vanishing point is
it spills the beans on everything that's
going on with regards to like what's up
with this classic Captain America
character it's so cool man is so excited
I love secret fire anyway so what we do
here we're really into a little bit of a
little bit of a catch-up thing for this
this a little bit of a story and it
works because what this initially does
is it picks up with alpha flight now
again alpha flight is kind of this
all-encompassing team which is to say
under normal circumstances alpha flight
station is just the old Canadian
alpha flight team that was never
relevant which is now operating out of a
space station and still isn't relevant
but they basically serve as this kind of
monitoring force or the universe
remember in Marvel Comics you have all
different kinds of organizations you
have the hand which contrary to what the
defenders say the hand were never part
of Conlin now the only thing the
defenders got right about the hand was
that they operate behind the scenes
influencing governments politicians the
whole nine yard
but the fact remains here with the
different organizations that exist in
Marvel alpha fly basically took the
place of sword now sword stands for the
sentient world observation and response
department and they basically existed
alongside shield where shield monitored
earth sword monitored space they
monitored other planets the races and so
on and so forth to make sure there were
no credible threats to earth that was
the normal role they played the reason
why that's important is because all this
really seems to focus on Carol Danvers
in the beginning which is to say for the
first few pages or so in this little bit
of a story Carol Danvers actually ends
up just kind of speaking in terms of how
she views everything and what's gone
down that's kind of the crazy situation
about this because she's currently
speaking to quasar as quasar exists in
the Marvel Universe now we'll talk about
the power of quasar here in a little bit
because I feel like this will be a
pretty cool discussion point when it
comes to her character just because of
the fact that we kind of have to know a
little bit about quasar in order to
understand everything that's going on
that might be something we discuss in
the next video because quasar is a
little more important in the next video
that she isn't this one but the idea is
that carol danvers hits back to
everything that had happened
going into all-new all-different marvel
and even before then and that's one of
the reasons why a lot of fans who look
at marvel at the moment they feel a
little disenfranchised in terms of their
attention to marvel the money they've
paid the readership the whole nine yards
much in the same way the classic DC fans
felt when DC rebooted with the new 52 so
again everything you know all this has
happened before and all of this will
happen again to quote Battlestar
Galactica the idea here is a Carol
Danvers basically says she had always
spent so much time trying to prove
herself as a legitimate hero that
ultimately she got carried away with her
attempts to show that she knew what she
was doing and that's true to a degree
historically speaking up until about
2012 with the first launch of Marvel now
Marvel now 1.0 Carol Danvers was always
a background character she basically had
two major roles in her life the first
one was basically being the vector by
which rogue gained her powers which is
to say rogue latched on to Carol Danvers
held her for too long and then basically
copied her powers and that's what made
rogue so powerful and so cool the other
half of this was immortus giving birth
to himself by way of Carol Danvers don't
ask why that story's confusing and it's
stupid but it's one of the things that
ended up happening with her character
but up until 2012 she was never relevant
why that matters is because in 2012
because carol danvers origin story
basically saw her gaining the powers of
the original Captain Marvel she had
always been living up to his mantle she
always idolized him in 2012 with the
original Marvel now Carol Danvers
basically became the new Captain Marvel
because that was just the role that she
needed to take everybody said hey look
you've basically been taking his role
for years and years and years it's time
for you to just take the name too and so
because that if saw her escapades going
into space and it was a really really
beautiful series of stories with her
character in terms of how she unfolded
the problem with this is that when
all-new all-different marvel kicked off
suddenly she was a bad guy suddenly she
was someone who was just like we have to
stop crime before it happens you know
and all this nonsense and it was really
a total 180 from the character that we
were used to but the common thread was
that in the classic stories the way she
was written she was always trying to
prove she was a legitimate hero she was
always trying to prove that hey look I
can hold my own and she could Carol
Danvers was a force to be reckoned with
she was not a pushover
she had energy manipulation powers she
basically had super strength speed
durability she could fly she was like a
female version of Superman who could
shoot energy it was really really cool
but the goal here is she's basically
simply saying everything that's
transpired has happened because of her
during the Civil War two storyline with
the whole idea of Ulysses being able to
see the future
she started engineering circumstances
the creation of a shield to protect the
world arresting people for committing
crimes before they happen different
things like that in doing so she had
literally split the superhuman community
in half she had you know assured in the
second Civil War and the result is that
Captain America as a Hydra agent used
that rift in the superhero community to
navigate those waters to chart that
course and catapult himself to the top
by conquering the United States and
allowing Hydra to reign supreme so in a
lot of ways everything that's happened
with secret Empire is Carol Danvers
fault now that begs the question is it
possible things have could have turned
out a different way well I mean sure
it's counting books you could write in
any number of ways but the idea is that
in terms of just what goes on here this
most likely would have happened anyway
because the superhero community in
Marvel Comics has always been fractured
the Avengers are always fighting against
some enemy somewhere but there's always
a lot of infighting as though it was
only a matter of time before something
like this happen
now the other half of this is that this
also follows Black Widow because
remember
romanov following the events of the last
video that we talked about where the
Incredible Hulk was just unleashed
before his death and he basically
destroyed the entirety of the Avengers
bunker and left them open to attack from
Hydra Black Widow had basically looked
at this and said Captain America needs
to die but the reason why this is cool
is because this all goes back to civil
war to remember the great big huge
revelation that came at a civil war - is
that Miles Morales spider-man is
supposed to kill Captain America and
that's really miles biggest fear keep in
mind for those of you guys who were new
Miles Morales was originally spider-man
from the Ultimate Universe which is to
say kind of a more updated contemporary
retelling of superheroes for really the
new generation but when Secret Wars
happened when the collapse of the
multiverse took place Miles Morales was
rolled in to the main Marvel Universe
and then just kind of operated as his
own superhero but during the events of
Civil War two ulysses forced all the
superheroes to see a future where the
united states was an almost complete and
total disarray where the capital
building was just torn all asunder and
amidst it all Miles Morales looked like
he had basically killed Captain America
and so what is up happening here is that
where miles is part of the champions and
miles has come with Black Widow for the
purpose of keeping an eye on her and
trying to aspire from killing Captain
America we also end up finding that he's
basically trapped she literally confined
him within the ship and the reason why
is because she says look Captain America
is gonna die but if he's gonna die he's
gonna die in my hands my hands are gonna
be the ones that are sullied and that's
kind of the cool thing here that's why
Natasha Romanov is always a little
interesting there's always something
about her that usually takes the reader
by surprise because she is a
cold-blooded dyed-in-the-wool killer
that's all she does she's just one of
the best assassins in the world but for
Miles Morales he's still young he's
unsullied by the mark of death more or
less
he's unsullied by all these different
things that could basically turn him
into a bad guy the goal Natasha Romanoff
is to make sure that innocence stays now
this whole idea is basically coming by
way of Captain America on the capitol
grounds making a speech and the goal
here is to basically bring in members of
Congress because Congress is still
intact and simply say you guys support
what hydras doing don't you now this is
kind of the cool thing because when it
comes to like ruling a country or
conquering a country people will usually
only ever fight back they'll usually
only ever revolt when they feel like
they have no other choice but as long as
there's food on their table as long as
there's clothes on their backs and the
backs of their children as long as
there's a roof over their head and the
head of their children they have no
reason to fight they're not backed up
against the wall and that's what you do
in a situation like this you let people
continue to use the Internet you censor
it you regulate it but you let it leak
out there's these dark spots that you
can't see these little sections where
you just can't monitor you can but you
let people believe that you can't they
congregate in those small areas and you
weed them out you set up traps and so
ultimately they're just a dog chasing
its tail and that's the beauty of
Captain America's Hydra he's leading the
people to believe that there is actual
progress going on he's leading the
people to believe they actually have a
chance to revolt the funny thing about
this is that that belief will become
absolute truth and the reason why is
because we actually end up finding out
that the old man who's basically
confined in this bed the old man that we
had talked about in previous videos this
old man is basically housing mosaic now
mosaic is an inhuman who basically has
the ability to possess people he's
introduced or really kind of brought in
as a character that can turn the time
and the reason why is because what
Natasha Romanoff needs is a distraction
firing off a shot into Hydra and killing
Captain America would inevitably you
know that would result on him being gone
but she would end up being captured
probably tortured and then eventually
killed the goal is to take out Captain
America and then become part of the
rebuilding process and so what ends up
happening here is that with mosaic
basically jumping from Hydra agent Hydra
agent creating this sort of turmoil and
chaos possessing this guy of these guys
forcing them to kill each other what it
does is it creates mass pandemonium and
mass chaos and with this chaos happening
the goal that Tasha Romanov is to shoot
Captain America the problem with this is
that while she's in the middle of doing
that she suddenly met with the arrival
of the Punisher and that's what make
this so cool because remember the
punisher joined hydra now we didn't
initially know why we weren't really
told why this was the case all we knew
is that the punisher allied himself with
captain america now the explanation
that's given to us is a captain america
had basically given punisher and how he
had gone to frank castle and said hey
look you've been waging this war against
crime your entire life you've been
killing criminals after they've
committed a crime what if
told you I would give you an army I
would give you the means to go through
and kill every single criminal that
exists what would you say to that free
castles answer is absolutely yes and
that fits perfectly in line with Frank
Castle because the idea is that for
Frank Castle all he wants to do is kill
criminals but wait he's given the given
the option to go through and just
achieve his goal in the extreme why
would he turn that down it'd be
absolutely foolish to do so and so you
know at the behest of Captain America he
seeks out Natasha Romanoff and ends up
beating the absolute hell out of her now
one thing to keep in mind is that in a
lot of ways this normally shouldn't
happen Frank Castle is a great fighter
he's a special agent he's been trained
in all kinds of different martial arts
and weapons uses so on and so forth but
he's no Black Widow if it came down to
it under any normal circumstance
Black Widow would beat the hell out of
him that's really not up for debate
Frank Castle couldn't really hold his
own against etosha Romanoff or any man
any measure of taunt
this just kind of gives us a different
take on the scenario so again it's a
little bit out of character for these
two guys when etosha Romanoff ultimately
makes her escape and the reason why is
because she notices that Miles Morales
is going to find Captain America but
with her basically bailing out this
begins to bring into fruition the idea
of what it is that Captain America has
been doing and the idea that Miles
Morales is gonna take him out now keep
in mind everybody saw that prediction of
Ulysses including Steve Rogers himself
the difference here is that when Steve
Rogers saw that prediction he realized
that Hydra had won in that future
and so it didn't matter to him if Miles
Morales killed him because the goal of
Hydra would continue on Hydra would rule
the country and eventually the world and
so in his mind sacrificing his life is a
small price to pay to ensure the dream
of hydras rule continues to live on the
problem with this is that when Natasha
Romanov goes to intervene in an attempt
to stop Miles Morales from potentially
killing Captain America Captain America
breaks her neck with his shield now this
is huge because Natasha Romanoff is one
of the few characters and I'm prudish
I'm pretty sure I'm accurate when I say
this she's one of the few characters in
Marvel Comics who's never died there's
never been an instance that I know of
where Natasha Romanoff has been killed
not only that this sets off the attack
from Miles Morales and this is when we
start to get that big picture because
remember when Ulysses originally gave
everybody
glimpse into the future that saw Miles
Morales killing Captain America it was
just that it was tantamount to taking a
photograph and then saying here's what
the future looks like sure you get that
one moment in time but you don't get the
full circumstance you don't get the full
explanation of what it was that was
happening now what we end up finding out
is that this is the reason why the
Captain America was a Hydra agent had
conquered America had killed Black Widow
along with a multitude of other
superheroes and Miles Morales had just
had enough now in this moment when he's
getting ready to kill Steve Rogers when
Steve Rogers is gonna die he's convinced
by the daughter of Hank Pym and Janet
Van Dyne not to do this and so again
that's where the tide begins to change
now again this all goes back into
Ulysses because we didn't know what
happened after we just got this quick
moment Ulysses is like look what's gonna
happen with the superhero community
Miles Morales was gonna kill Captain
America and everybody was like my god
and then that's it that's all we get we
didn't get the aftermath it's entirely
possible this was exactly what was going
to happen it's also possible that
because this glimpse was given to
everybody this is what happened that had
that glimpse not happen from Ulysses de
Moz Welles would have just killed
Captain America and that would have been
it no muss no fuss Hydra was basically
defeated and that's the kind of funny
thing about this is because Hydra itself
may have engineered his own destruction
and so the result is that following the
attempted you know killing of Captain
America by Miles Morales of course miles
is [ __ ] leaked basically captured and
so ultimately we end up having Sharon
Carter brought before Captain America
now remember Sharon Carter is a
character who for quite some time has
not seen herself as an ally of Steve
Rogers once he came out and declared
himself as a Hydra agent she basically
walked away she said I'm not having
anything to do with this but for the
most part she's been kept as a prisoner
under the guise the Captain America can
basically bring her over to his side now
cheering Carter is not particularly
important it's really just an emotional
thing because the two of them were
together for quite some time they were
love interest they were meant to be a
thing but in this moment when Captain
America shows weakness Sharon Carter
tries to kill him now this is huge
because this is a throwback to the
original death of Captain America's
story and the original event bottle
means Civil War and you know going into
Avengers the initiative I think it was
and then eventually the death of Steve
Rogers what we had learned in that
particular story way back in 2000 and
seven 2008-2009 some one of those lines
is that the Red Skull had basically
brought in a guy named dr. Fausta's who
had the ability to hypnotize people into
committing acts Sharon Carter was
basically the killing blow the way that
original event unfolded is that
crossbones was a distraction crossbones
fired a shot into Steve Rogers shoulder
Sharon Carter ran to his aid and then
she fired a couple shots into his
stomach in his chest and that was the
end of Captain America almost
immediately after that happened we
learned that dr. Faust this was the one
that had been brainwashing her into
doing that in the first place but again
this all goes back to that idea the
difference here is that Sharon Carter's
not killing him because she's
brainwashed she's trying to kill him
because she just genuinely hates him and
so this is really mixed Spencer saying
Captain America's crossed a line that he
can't come back from if the one person
that he should be able to confide in the
most absolutely tries to kill him
because she despises him he's long gone
there's no way to redeem him and so what
this seems to indicate here is that when
this story ends it will not come by way
of Hydra Captain America waking up and
realizing his mistakes to say my god
what have I done it'll be something else
going on that's something is explained
and a secret Empire issue number
knocking I really hope you guys are
current but the idea here we actually
end up picking up with this classic
Captain America and the Red Skull now
the funny thing about this is that Red
Skull tries to kill classic Captain
America but it doesn't look like he's
trying to do this because he's a bad guy
instead classic Captain America gets a
glimpse of this woman who's shrouded in
light and then is able to overcome the
Red Skull but what seemed to have
happened here is Red Skull intended to
kill classic Captain America to save him
but the idea is that classic Captain
America basically overcame the Red Skull
and literally destroyed his own way to
escape the vanishing point and so that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
the question is one who's this chick and
two what is the vanishing point now of
course back in the aftermath of the
death out of Tasha Romanoff everybody's
basically struggling with this in a
multitude of different ways really none
more so than Hawkeye because remember
Hawkeye and Black Widow go back quite
some ways they both basically appeared
around the same time over the course of
their publication histories they became
good guys and ultimately join the
Avengers but their histories go hand in
hand to say nothing of the romance
between the two of them so the whole
idea here is that there's and there's an
effort by the various superhero
community to try to find a way to rally
the problem with this is that the
champions in Miles Morales they've been
captured Natasha Romanov is dead the
bodies of the superhero community just
keep piling up and piling up and piling
up they're fighting a losing war there's
really no way that they can come out on
top here and so ultimately in the myths
of this idea when all hope is
effectively lost Sam Wilson one of my
absolute favorite characters ever
finally returns to the mantle of Captain
America which I am so hyped to see what
happens next
this is why I love secret Empire so much
I love Sam Wilson Captain America the
cod it's one of my absolute favorite
stories one my favorite favorite roles
for his character but yeah so if you
guys are new here to come just explain
and make sure you guys did a sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
guys in the next video peace
[Music]